do not be afraid to fail because that
oftentimes is the thing that keeps us as
women and girls back you give a woman a
problem she will go to hell and high
water to fix it and the problem with a
lot of us in the workplace is we play it
so safe that we don't push ourselves
right think of yourself as not a woman
not a minority not skinny not whatever
just think about like your art or the
thing you want to do
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
on to the world now I started the
girlboss series this is a new test this
is the first video in the series and I
hope it continues the goal is to try to
help motivate inspire young women
entrepreneurs to help them believe in
themselves more see that they can go off
and do amazing things build insanely
awesome companies and so I hope you
enjoyed this video I look forward to
your feedback please let me know down in
the comments below afterwards and enjoy
this video all right up first rule
number one fail your way to success with
Michelle Obama this is what I tell my
daughters every day do not be afraid to
fail because that often times is the
thing that keeps us as women and girls
back because we think we have to be
right and we think we have to be perfect
we think that we can't stumble and the
only way you succeed in life the only
way you learn is by failing it's not the
failure it's what you do after you fail
you know do you let it each up do you
quit do you give up or do you let it
bolster you does it serve as as the
challenge in your mind to do more to
take some risks to step outside of your
comfort zone rule number two is push
yourself with Mel Robbins men will apply
for a job when they feel that they are
60% qualified that's a risk right
because there's a gap there and anytime
you want to get a new assignment or you
want to kind of expand what you're doing
there will be a gap women consistent
we wait to either volunteer for
assignments or apply for more senior
jobs until they personally feel that
they are 100% ready and so it's really
important even though you're not going
to feel comfortable pushing yourself to
take a risk because if you apply and you
don't get it
guess what you can go to the the
sponsoring partner that was hiring for
that and say what's the gap right and
then you're gonna be told exactly what
are those things that you need to be
doing between now and the next time that
you apply that fills that gap right that
was there to begin with but without
taking those risks you have no idea what
the gaps are and you have no idea what
you need to go to work on one of the
things that I love about working with
women is we are natural problem solver
yes if you give a woman a problem she
will go to hell and high water to fix it
right and the problem with a lot of us
in the workplace as we play it so safe
because we're afraid to disappoint
people were afraid to get in trouble
we're afraid to lose our jobs and then
that's gonna impact the family that we
don't push ourselves right and the truth
is if you stick your neck out if you
summon up that grit and you act even
though it scares you to death you got a
problem right and now you're gonna fix
it that's right rule number three just
do your work with Mindy Kaling girls
faced so many challenges and people are
constantly telling them they can't do
things that can't be funny they can't
run companies that I just I mean my
advice is always just like not to focus
on anyone telling you you can't do
anything or the politics of your
situation but to just focus on the
situation it's sort of to think of
yourself as not a woman not a minority
not skinny not whatever just think about
like your art or the thing you want to
do because you you can get caught up I
can get caught up I could spend my
entire life doing panels on being a
chubby woman of color writing a TV show
and everyone it would be useful to some
people that I wouldn't be writing in my
TV show and all my competition all the
white men who are doing the same thing
as me are
not doing those panels they're just
getting better and better and better at
their job and so for me the only advice
I ever give women is like we want to
support each other without distracting
each other and it's just like head heads
down work really hard pretending your
parents don't like you know they lock
you into the third room of whatever and
just like do your work so I it's not fun
advice it's not like look in the mirror
and just say like RESP ECT and like walk
down the street but I was just that was
not my experience rule number four stand
up for your beliefs with Jennifer
Lawrence when the Sony hack happened and
I and I saw the difference and pay I
spoke out because I knew what led to
that I knew that there was no one to
blame but myself I knew that it wasn't
so nice fault that it was it was what
would I had done with my own mentality
there's almost a gender bias that we as
women I can only speak as a woman as
I've never been a man but as a woman we
almost put this gender bias and
ourselves maybe possibly that's why I
wanted to just open up and say I feel
this way I feel awkward negotiating I
feel uncomfortable asking for more money
I don't want to seem like a brat I don't
want to seem like all of these things
that are only words that are used for
women they don't have those words for
males and if this can help somebody
great but because you don't you had
gained the strength and courage to do it
yeah I think I've got I you know it's
been an awkward process because I'm
growing up a little bit in the spotlight
so it's I used to just keep my mouth
shut you know about everything because
my job depends on everyone going to see
my movies not just people who agree with
my opinions and people don't really like
opinionated actors and
or any celebrity's so it's scary to do
it because you know that you could be
losing friends or box office tickets but
as I get older and I learn more and I
and I have opinions I go yeah but III
don't have I have just as much of a
right to speak and was something like
that was something that's so clearly
unfair if I don't use my voice for women
who don't have a voice and what's the
point rule number five dream bigger with
Cara Delevingne it's just there's a lot
of things I want to do I always wanted
to be a director I think as well I have
so many girls come out to me and tell me
that they want to be models which is
fine it's not a bad thing I just think
there's so much to do I just went to a
wonderful talk about genetic engineering
and neuroscience and this man who is
giving the talk explained it this is
like 10,000 kids is from the age of 7 to
13 who are doing neuroscience they do
these competitions and wonderful things
and they're doing things in your science
which haven't been which weren't done by
him until he was like 30 like how
quickly things like that are changing
and but they're not there is an
awareness sport it's cool stuff like
that like that sounds way cooler to me
than being a model but like no one
really knows about it and I just think
there are just so many things I always
say two cars into the dream just dream
bigger go for president just keep going
up astronauts I don't know rule number
six work on yourself with Oprah Winfrey
I say to them my girls all of the time
that your real work is to figure out
where your power base is and to work on
the alignment of your personality your
gifts that you have to give with the
real reason why you're here that's
that's the number one thing you have to
do is to work on yourself and to fill
your self up and keep your cup full keep
yourself full now I
used to be afraid of that I used to be
afraid particularly from people who say
oh she said she's so full of herself
she's so close herself and now I embrace
it I I considered a compliment that I am
full of myself because you only when
you're full I'm full I'm overflowing my
cup runneth over I have so much I have
so much to offer and so much to give and
I am not afraid of honoring myself you
know it's miraculous when you think
about it
rule number seven go for growth with
Sheryl Sandberg I do believe that women
don't take enough risk not every woman
certainly some do but same thing the men
are just foot on the gas pedal career
motivated the data sells very clearly
that at every stage starting in college
in the high educated part of our
workforce men are more ambitious than
women and I really believe we're not
gonna close the achievement gap until we
close the ambition gap and so the
ambition gap has to do with risk I think
the most common mistake I see people
make and men make this mistake too but
women do do a lot is they're too worried
about the upward trajectory and not
worried enough about growth so the two
corporate jobs I've taken I went from
Treasury to Google and I went from
Google to Facebook had one thing in
common which is that they were more
junior other people's words not mine
than other jobs I was offered when I
went to Google Google was like 250
people I was gonna be a business unit
general manager except there were no
business units Susan Wojcicki is here
she helped recruit me this was the non
job of all time I mean there was no job
there and I was offered like senior
sounding see more senior roles at more
established companies but I really
believed in what Google was doing and
Eric Schmidt gave me great career advice
he said go for growth growth moves
everyone up it was growing it works and
so I went to a smaller company with a
very more junior less defined job you
know when I came out of Google it seems
obvious now to come to Facebook but at
the time a lot of people asked me right
you remember this what are you doing
you're going to work for a 23 year olds
you know no one knows that Facebook's
gonna be the next you know MySpace or
Friendster like and you're not CEO you
could be CEO somewhere else and what I
saw was something that mattered Facebook
mattered that authentic identity and an
opportunity for growth and so at each
stage I've cared less about my level I
kind of think it's silly then I have
about the underlying growth and I do
think this is really important for
everyone to know particularly women and
rule number eight the last one before
the bonus clip is don't ask for
permission with Ava Duvernay
for young people women people of color
as a young african-american woman
director what words of wisdom do you
have to share as you not look back on
your career but you continue to go
forward that's exactly what it is it's
go forward you know we have to work
without permission especially as women
in this industry who are we asking for
permission to do what we want to do that
should be eradicated you need to set a
path and start walking and that is what
I've tried to do and what I try to
encourage folks to do walk with me let
me walk with you let's walk with each
other but I think you know so much of
the industry is very permission-based
and once you get out of your mind that
you have to ask anyone to do what you
want to do you'll be better for it now
I've got a special bonus clip from Jack
Ma for everybody but before that my
question of the day is I'm curious what
did you think of this series should we
continue it or not do you have any
suggestions or feedback for me that I
can use to carry it forward let me know
I need your feedback I want you to
support leave it down the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus
today we have a 49% closed 49% of the
employees of our company are women
that's a lot for a high-tech company
it's not on purpose with high women we
think they are great in helping us to
grow Alibaba is an e-commerce company
ecommerce is a service industry to serve
people better you have should have a
surf hub service part we find that women
doing much better jobs than men and the
second is the last century people
compete become muscle no not this
century is not much as the wisdom and
next is I believe if a person want to be
successful we should have a high EQ but
if you don't want to lose quickly you
should have a high IQ but if you want to
be respected
you should have have high lq the cue of
love so those three cues put together a
lot of men they have a high IQ below EQ
on a very tiny lq women balance wise
they're the best if you want your
company to be successful if you want
your company to operate with wisdom with
care wonder is the best in my company we
noticed that women they care others much
more than men even our site today our
shopping site ecommerce we found a woman
buy a lot of things but they buy for
their husband their parents their kids
may only buy for themselves mostly
because you care that make you the
difference so we have a 49% of the the
colleagues in the company of women and
clothes 37% of the senior management a
woman we never feel anything wrong and
women they they they sacrifice more like
when they they love it they believe it
they continue to do it so I think the
very one of the secret sauce for Alibaba
to be successful was successfully in the
past eighteen years because we have so
many women colleagues and the other
thing is that with you so proud and you
know most of the time you see I go out I
never realized that when we can't always
fifty percent of women with my
delegation my team because we never
think they're women we think they're
great a colleague's raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion and
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details